never Lawrence whose son Steven was
murdered in southeast London 25 years
ago says he's forgiven his son's killers
mr. Lawrence has spent years of course
fighting for justice for his son well
I'm delighted to say that Neville is
here in the studio with me yeah very
good morning morning this is incredible
that you have decided to forgive the
killers why I came from a very religious
family unfortunately a while I was here
in in England I wasn't able to practice
my religion the way I'm doing it now
since I've moved to Jamaica
I decided I wanted to be baptized in
order to baptize you have to forgive
people who have done you wrong before
you can go into this baptism it's been a
heavy load to carry around and an eight
Raju's not a nice thing to have and so
in order to free myself of this burden
of carrying this burden around I decided
to give forgive all these boys who
racially motivated murder of my son were
you hoping the perhaps they might ask
you for forgiveness well I thought that
once one time that if you wanted to
forgive somebody they'd ad for hogs for
your forgiveness
not so you can forgive somebody whether
or not they want it or not if by any
chance these people repent from what
they've done an ox to see me I would
consider going and talking to them it's
25 years since Stephen died the
anniversary is on Sunday 25 years it's a
long time to lose a child is unthinkable
for any parent how have you managed to
keep going for quarter of a century have
you managed to get out of bed every
morning well that's one of the reason
why I have to forgive people because
that extra burden of carrying around
video with the trauma of losing your
firstborn is very heavy and so
forgiveness we say our our Father every
day and in
father prior you'll say forgive us our
sins and if you are oxen for forgiveness
you should be able to forgive as well so
that's one of the reason why I decided
to forgive them we've heard so much
haven't we
in recent weeks about knife crime
there's been this horrific spike in
stabbings in the capital that must upset
you greatly well yes because it reminds
me of the first the first night our on
the day after the death of my son and I
always wondered how these people is
going to cope with something as
devastating as that I'm now the vise I'm
no the chair of our organization which
was set up by the Metropolitan Police
we've just started to gather some people
around to try and find some ways to kind
of help the stem describe of on knife
crime we haven't got all the answers
so the fact I normally go into schools
and and go and talk to young people is
going to be helping to try and find out
around the reason and some of the
reasons that they do carry knives so
we're hoping that we're going to be
launched maybe in June and then after
that we're going to see how what we can
do to try and stem the tide of this
knife crime situation you go into
schools never when you go into
communities and you speak to all sorts
of different people where do you think
the problem lies lots of different
issues why you have these problems on
the street because there's no way for
these kids to go right before you had
community centers another place where
they could go and spend time you maybe
learn something like boxing or something
to better themselves all those things
have been taken away organization that
used to try and help young people they
no longer exist because they haven't got
the funding or the money to do some of
these things so we've got to just get
people to go and research and use the
research that we get to transfer and
stop this knife crime situation at the
moment do you speak to other parents
who've lost children
I've always made a plane to any family
who's been to anything near like my
family's been true if they're arcs for
me to go and speak to them I do that
I've been speaking to quite a few
families over the years and the one of
the reason why I did that is because
when my son was killed some of the
families left with was when true this
situation before came and spoke to me
and kind of make you aware of the road
that you had you go gonna be traveling
down so for me to go and talk to other
people is something that I like to do
the Met Police never have said that it's
unlikely the investigation will progress
any further until there's new evidence
there'll be people watching this this
morning that are astounded really that
you can forgive a bunch of racists your
faith has been very important to you but
not everyone will be able to forgive no
everyone won't be fit we were able to
forgive but as I just said about the
fact that you arcs of forgiveness I
think users find in yourself at some
stage to do that to let go and try and
live your life although is so painful at
the same time it's all rewarding as well
because I've noticed since I've decided
which I got baptized on the 13th of
January last year and the reason why I
chose that date is that Steve was born
on the 13th of September and I was born
on the 13th of March and I thought this
was going to be a new life that I were
going to start so I did it on the 13th
the perfect date do you think about what
Steven would be doing now
what sort of man he would be well that
goes through my brain and it goes
through my mind every time I see when I
speak to young people and CEO someone
because you know some of the sounds when
you you hear news about how bad these
people are or not by these young people
are we never hear about some of the good
things that these young people are still
doing and we have to commend some of
these youngsters of what they have done
after the circumstances that they are in
and so hard to get on with their life
but they have done and there's lots of
organization or they're trying to young
laughter young to help young people as I
said the anniversary is on Sunday what
will you be doing well I've decided that
I'm going to be in church for that day
I'm going to be trying to console myself
and I'm trying to be calm under spend
the day thinking about the good Lord was
brought the tool or the site because it
once said I thought I wouldn't live to
see my 60th birthday Steve was murdered
when I was 51 I'm no 76 so I what I
didn't think how would he reach this age
never we've been so impressed by your
dignity over the years we appreciate you
coming in and our thoughts are with you
at what inevitably will be a difficult
time Stevens anniversary of his death
thank you very much thank you very much